so that is
uh a press conference from brussels and
that is
it ladies and gentlemen that is the
post-brexit
trade deal it has been announced that it
has been
agreed it has to be ratified uh signed
off by both sides we heard there from
michelle barnier
uh the chief negotiator for the eu
saying that eu consent
will be given in the new year uh first
we heard
from ursula van der lyon the european
union
commission president uh who said that it
was a good deal she said it was fair
balanced responsible from both sides
uh really a sense of relief from her
saying finally we're able to leave
brexit behind us
wanting to continue the special
relationship with the uk
she mentioned uh the five year five and
a half years of predictability for
fishing communities talking about
the phasing in there of quotas
at the end there she said or questioned
rhetorically what does sovereignty
really mean
going on to talk about how for her it
means seamlessly working and doing
business across 27 different countries
uh
she did thank the uk for being tough but
fair negotiation
negotiating partners uh let's go to
bernard smith who is standing by for us
in paris bernard you were listening in
there what did you make of what ursula
vonderline had to say
well there was certainly no triumphalism
and in fact one of the things ursula van
der laan says would normally have to
trade
negotiations there are celebrations but
she said today i only feel
quiet quiet satisfaction and relief
and she says to our friends in the uk
quoting shakespeare she said i want to
say
that parting is such sweet sorrow the
priorities for the european union were
to maintain the integrity
of the single market urschel von deland
says they've done that
she says our single market will remain
will be fair and remain
so and we have effective tools to react
if their competition is distorted one of
the main
areas of discussion throughout these
negotiations was that there remains a
level playing field between the united
kingdom
and the european union and the
mechanisms for making sure that this
level playing field
is observed they've clearly now in this
2000 page
document which is yet to be digested by
everybody outside
agreed a mechanism for making sure that
they can
make sure that they can stick to a level
playing field
and she said that uh together
we were uh still stronger more than we
were
apart but nevertheless uh she says that
uh the european union remains one of the
giants
in world trade and the european uh and
that is the
mood she was suggesting the indication
she was giving
was that britain will be missed but
they've negotiated
tough and fair negotiations it's a shame
that britain has left the european union
that's what
ursula van der leyen is trying to say
once has been saying in the past
but we have now a new relationship with
them and very interestingly
specifically on fishing which was that
last thing
that was holding up an agreement or
signing off in the agreement
the eu says they've got five and a half
years of full product predictability
uh on uh what eu uh
fishermen will be able to get in british
waters we don't
quite know what the detail of that is
yet but we will be finding it out soon
enough
okay thank you for that bird smith there
uh across the european side
from paris let's go to essay bake who is
standing by for us
outside downing street i said we assume
there's probably communication between
the eu and the uk because we are waiting
for boris johnson to speak they didn't
speak over top of each other
uh so we are waiting for boris johnson
to speak what have we heard from the uk
so far
well we've had a statement from the uk
and i feel it's a
bit of a different tone the uk uh
government is saying that they have
achieved everything that they promised
for the british
uh british people during the referendum
they say that they have taken back
control of their money
borders laws trade and our fishing
waters
and they said that this is a fantastic
news for families and businesses and
there will be
zero tariffs and zero quotas they go on
to say
that they will no longer so sorry they
said that the deal also guarantees that
they were no longer
in a lunar pool of the eu they say we
are not banned by eu
rules and there's no role for the
european court of justice and the key
red lines about returning sovereignty
have been achieved and again this is
that brexit has been done and is a
fantastic opportunity for the uk
to achieve trade deals with other
countries around the world
whereas the european union is saying
that look
they did they didn't want the uk to
leave now that they have
is a sense of relief for the uk for the
british government they've really been
trying to work hard
to get this deal to get the brexit done
that was something that prime minister
boris johnson has been campaigning on it
was part of his
prime minister prime ministerial ship is
a part of his legacy as a part of
who he essentially is as a politician
now
and he will very much want to own this
and make it seem like is a very good
deal
although no one has really seen this
2000 page document yet
and it still has to be scrutinized by
members of parliament but already this
morning the papers here
that were campaigning for brexit have
said that this is a victory
and i'm sure prime minister boris
johnson would want to capitalize on that
and make this seem like it is the best
thing that he has been able to achieve
for the united kingdom
we'll get you to stay with us i said uh
now if a picture uh
says a thousand words take a look at
this uh this is boris johnson
tweeting about 17 minutes ago the deal
is done uh victorious looking
indeed uh and then after that he's been
tweeting uh
live stream links so people can watch
uh his press conference which we are
expecting to happen
any minute now if you have just joined
us a brexit trade deal
has been announced from the european
commission
side we heard from uh the european uh
sorry the president of the european
commission us lavonda lyon
who made that announcement calling it a
good deal a fair deal a balanced
deal uh a big part of the eu the
powerhouse says they call it germany
uh let's go live now to dominic kane who
is live for us in berlin
have we heard anything yet dominic from
any german officials
no german ministers have spoken publicly
yet
regarding this deal arrived at between
the european commission
and the british government but it's
worth making the point and reiterating
that ursula fonder lion the president of
the european commission
is a very senior german politician
indeed
very privy to the private discussions
that
angela merkel the chancellor here would
have been having for many years about
brexit remember that ursula funder line
used to be a very senior cabinet
minister here in germany and so when
when a silicon de lion speaks you know
that the sorts of thoughts that she has
and the sorts of thoughts that she
makes public are very much those which
have been informing the mentality
ministerially
here in berlin people will recall that
angela merkel has always said that
whilst it is very sad to see the united
kingdom exit the european union
up amongst in everyone's minds was the
interests collectively
of the 27 remaining member states in the
european union so it is
quite likely that she will share the
thoughts that we were hearing
earlier that anger that uh ursula fonda
lion
was saying about the sweet sorrow of the
parting of the
united kingdom and the european union
it's also worth considering some of the
words that michel bernier the negotiator
for the european union in these
negotiations
was saying he said while speaking in
french that the united kingdom had
chosen to renounce
the rights and benefits that it had as a
member of the european union and could
not expect
to retain most of those rights and
benefits
having left the european union that is
very much
what the german government has always
said about
what it would want to see happen as a
result of whatever deal
would emerge from the negotiations and
it was clear angela merkel had always
said
didn't want to see a no deal but the
most important thing paramount of
importance was the
collective best interests of the 27
countries
and so as i say it is likely that when
we get some sort of ministerial comment
about
what has happened in brussels and london
that it will
closely mirror the sorts of sentiment
that we saw there from uh
and heard from ursula fonder lion and
from michelle bernier
okay thank you so much for that dominic
kane there live for us in berlin
well joining us now from london is
philippe le grand he
is a financial analyst and former
economic advisor to the president of the
european commission thank you for your
time sir
so the eu commission has said it won't
be able to ratify
this before the end of the year what
does that mean for the implementation
of this trade agreement by the december
31 deadline
well what's going to happen to happen is
it's going to have to be applied
provisionally because the european
parliament set a deadline
of sunday passed for a deal to be done
that
that obviously deadline was missed and
so uh
the as long as the european council eu
governments
are prepared to go ahead it can be
applied provisionally
and then the european parliament will
have to formally ratify it
sometime early next year the uk
parliament is due to meet
on the 30th of december
at presumably to uh to vote to ratify
them
what are the uk's economic forecasts
looking like as a result of this deal
but also taking into account the
pandemic and the new strain of course
that's been found in the uk
well obviously in the short term the
coronavirus pandemic and all the
associated
uh lockdowns and so on is the having the
biggest
harmful impact on the uk and indeed the
global
economy and clearly it's also good news
uh that
a chaotic no deal brexit has been
avoided
uh which would have been uh extremely
costly uh economically and compounded
uh the covet crisis at the same time has
has been expressed
um by president fond de leon and others
this is a step back uh from uh the level
of economic integration that the uk
currently enjoys with the eu
the uk is leaving the single market and
the customs union
and while there may not be a tariffs and
quotas
on goods trade there will be new customs
and laboratory barriers
trading services in which the uk
specializes everything from
finance and accounting uh to
architecture
and consultancy that's going to be much
less free than before
and the free movement of people more
broadly uh is ending
so in effect um it's great news uh that
uh a chaotic disaster has been avoided
at the same time they're opting for uh
managed
disintegration instead and that too will
be costly
do you know or do you have an idea of
which industries
in the uk will be better off and which
perhaps will be worse off
as a result of this agreement i know
we're waiting to hear the the details of
this apparently two thousand page report
but but
what's your sense of which industries
are going to do well and which perhaps
not so much
well clearly the industries which are
purely domestically focused or the ones
which primarily export
outside the european union are going to
be
at least affected by this
in terms of the
trading services in which as i said the
eu specializes
one big question that remains unanswered
is whether
the financial sector is going to be able
to enjoy
something like not quite as good but at
least
reasonably good access to its eu client
and that depends on whether the european
commission determines that
our uk financial regulations are
equivalent
to its own another question obviously
which is relevant for everyone in the
tech sector and more broadly every
business that uses
um data is a continuing determination
that
uk data privacy regulations are adequate
and that may pose problems going forward
with the uk seemingly seeking to seek
advantage
in technology areas by stripping away
some of those regulations leave it there
because
the british prime minister boris johnson
has taken the stage let's listen in
the british people voted to take back
control of their money their borders
their laws and their waters and to leave
the european union
and earlier this year we fulfilled that
promise that we left
on january the 31st with that oven ready
deal
since that time we've been getting on
with our agenda enacting
the points-based immigration system that
you voted for that will come into force
on january the 1st
doing free trade deals with 58 countries
around the world and preparing the new
relationship
with the eu and there have been plenty
of people who have told us
that the challenges of the covid
pandemic
have made this work impossible and that
we should
extend the transition period and incur
yet more
delay and i rejected that approach
precisely because
beating kovid is our number one national
priority and i wanted to end any extra
uncertainty and to give this country the
best possible chance of
bouncing back strongly next year and so
i'm very pleased to tell you uh this
afternoon
uh that we have completed the biggest
trade deal yet
worth 660 billion pounds a year
a comprehensive canada style free trade
deal
between the uk and the eu a deal
that will protect jobs across this
country it will allow
goods uk goods and components to be sold
without tariffs and without quotas
in the eu market a deal which will if
anything
allow our companies and our exporters to
do even more business with our european
friends and yet
which achieves something that the people
of this country
instinctively knew was doable
but which they were told was impossible
we've taken back control
of our laws and our destiny we've taken
back control of
every jot and tittle of our regulation
in a way that is complete
and unfettered from january the 1st
we are outside the customs union and
outside the single market
british laws will be made solely by the
british
parliament interpreted by uk judges
sitting in
uk courts and the jurisdiction of the
european court of justice
will come to an end we will be able to
set our own standards
to innovate in the way that we want to
originate new frameworks for the sectors
in which this country leads the world
from biosciences to financial services
artificial intelligence and beyond
we'll be able to decide how and where
we're going to stimulate new jobs and
new hope
with freeports new green industrial
zones
we'll be able to cherish our landscape
and our environment
in the way we choose backing our farmers
backing british food and agricultural
production
and for the first time since 1973
we will be an independent coastal state
with full control
of our waters with the uk's share of
fish in our waters rising substantially
from roughly
half today to closer to two-thirds
in five and a half years time after
which there is
no theoretical limit beyond those placed
by science or
conservation on the quantity of our own
fish that we can fish
in our waters and to get ready
for those for that moment those fishing
communities
will be helped with a big 100 million
pro
pound program to modernize their fleets
and
the fish processing industry
and i want to stress that uh although of
course the
the arguments with our european friends
and partners were uh were sometimes
uh fierce this this is i believe a good
deal
for the whole of uh of europe
uh and uh for our friends and partners
as well
because it will not be a bad thing in my
view for the eu to have a
prosperous and dynamic uh and contented
uk on your doorstep and it will be a
good thing
it will be it will drive jobs and
prosperity across
the whole continent and i don't think
it'd be a bad thing
if we in the uk do things differently or
take a different approach uh to
legislation because in so many ways our
basic
goals are the same and
in the context of this giant free trade
zone
that we're jointly creating the stimulus
of regulatory competition will i think
benefit
us both and if one side believes it's
somehow being
unfairly undercut by the other
then subject to independent third party
arbitration and provided the
measures are proportionate we can either
of us
decide as sovereign equals to protect
our consumers or businesses but this
treaty explicitly envisages
that such action should only happen
infrequently
and the concepts of uniformity and
harmonization are banished in favor of
mutual respect and mutual recognition
and
free trade and for for squaring that
circle
uh for finding uh the the philosopher's
stone that's enabled us to
to do this i want to thank a president
vandalian arsenal wonderland of the
european commission uh our brilliant
negotiators led by
lord frost and michelle barnier on the
eu
side uh as stephanie riso as well as
oliver lewis
tim barrow lindsay appleby many others
their work
will be available for scrutiny uh
followed by a parliamentary vote
uh i hope on december the 30th
this agreement this deal above all means
certainty
it means certainty for the aviation
industry and the hauliers
who have suffered so much in the kovid
pandemic it means
certainty for the police the border
forces the security services
all those we rely on across europe to
keep us all safe
it means certainty for our scientists
who will be able to work together
and continue to work together on great
collective
projects because although we want in the
uk to be a science
superpower we also want to be a
collaborative
science superpower and above all
it means certainty for business uh
from uh financial services to our world
leading manufacturers
our our car industry a certainty uh for
all those who are working in
high-skilled jobs
uh and in firms and factories across
the whole the whole country because
there will be no palisade of
tariffs on january the 1st and there'll
be no
non-tariff barriers to to trade instead
there will be a giant free trade zone of
which
we will once be a member and at the same
time
be able to do our own free trade deals
as one
uk whole and entire england
northern ireland scotland wales together
and
i should stress this deal was done by a
huge
negotiating team from every part of the
uk and it will benefit
every part of our united kingdom helping
to unite and level up across the country
and so i say again directly to our eu
friends and partners i think this deal
means a new stability and a new
certainty in what has sometimes been a
fractious
and difficult relationship we will be
your friend your ally
your supporter and indeed never let it
be
forgotten your number one market
because although we have left the eu
this country
will remain culturally emotionally
historically strategically
geologically attached
to europe not least of course through
the
four million eu nationals who have
requested to settle in the uk
over the last uh four years and who make
an enormous
contribution to uh our country and to
our lives
and i say to all of you at home at the
end of this toughest of years
that our focus in the weeks ahead is of
course on
defeating uh the the pandemic and on
beating coronavirus and rebuilding our
economy and
delivering jobs across the country
and i'm utterly confident that we can
and will do it
we've uh by today we vaccinated almost
800
000 people and we've also today
resolved a question that has bedeviled
our politics for decades and
it is up to us all together
as a newly and truly independent
nation to realize
the immensity of this moment
and to make the most of it happy
christmas
to you all that's the good news
from brussels now for the sprouts
actually it's known for the media
uh let's go let's go to the media who i
think uh we've got laura koonsberg
uh over to you laura thank you very much
prime minister
we're yet to see the text of this deal
which we understand runs to some 2000
pages you've presumably had the benefit
of pouring over
every word or maybe perhaps not every
single word but can you tell the public
honestly
where did the uk give the most ground
and where did the eu compromise the most
do you think
um thanks laura well actually tell me
about 500 pages
and uh i think it would and it's it's
readily intelligible
uh i i think uh i think that it would be
fair to say
that um we wanted
we wanted to uh make sure for instance
that
uh we got access to
uh got complete control of our
fisheries from the get-go that's just to
to say we had annual negotiations on
fisheries
uh within the shortest possible delay uh
the eu began with i think wanting
uh a transition period of 14 years
we wanted three years we've ended up at
five years
uh i think that was a reasonable uh a
reasonable transition period and
i can assure a great fish fanatics in
this country
we will as a result of this deal be able
to
uh catch and eat quite prodigious
quantities
of extra fish so uh it's that's why
we're gonna have to make these
investments in the
in the fishing sector thanks uh very
much laura
uh let's go to to robert pestonville tv
so robert you need to unmute you need to
unmute robert
yeah uh prime minister you said all
along
you wanted a canada style deal but what
you've agreed
means that we in the uk have to follow
eu rules on subsidies or tax on workers
rights on the environment
or potentially incur the imposition of
tariffs that's right isn't it i mean
we've just heard ursula wanderline say
that she got her level playing field
which you've explicitly rejected
all the way through you also just said
there would be no
non-tariff barriers again that's not
right from january the first as a result
of leaving the customs union and michael
gove has been warning about this week in
week out
for months there is a ton of new
bureaucracy on british
businesses lots of new non-tariff
barriers this is not to say the
deal is a bad deal but you're not
selling it correctly are you you're miss
selling it
no uh well i must respectfully uh
disagree with you
because there is indeed a clause in the
in the deal which uh is nothing like as
as damaging as it as it was and is in my
view
uh neutralized which says that uh
if either country feel that uh
the other one is in some way
undercutting them or dumping in
in some way then uh subject to uh
arbitration and provided the measure is
uh proportionate
uh and that i mean independent
arbitration not arbitration by the
european
court of justice but subject to
independent power they can if they
really choose
uh put on uh tariffs to to protect their
their consumers and their and their
businesses and to give you an example
the kind of thing where that might occur
for instance in the uk
uh we want to do uh go further on animal
welfare standards
and it might be that we do things for
instance on
how you how you rear pigs banning cya
crates and so on
that would incur extra costs for our uh
our pig farmers
uh and uh it might be that
bacon coming from elsewhere in in the
from from the uh eu was uh was
at risk of therefore abundance we might
under those circumstances consider uh
imposing tariffs i think it's highly
unlikely but we might
uh consider it it would have to be
subject to to arbitration
uh it would have to be proportionate
according to
uh the arbitrator and under no
circumstances
would we be in any way constrained
legally or otherwise by anything that
the eu
did or chose to do themselves
nor furthermore would there be any
a role for the european court of justice
and for for people at home who've zoned
out while i've been talking about this
uh let me tell you this is a very very
long day's march
uh from uh where we were a few years ago
you will remember
robert when we were talking about
basically having a common rulebook
with the eu and having dynamic alignment
uh with eu law so that the uk was forced
to
to keep step and uh that has gone uh
from this treaty in so far as the
uh eu wanted it and there is no
uh role for the european court of
justice uh whatever so
i think it's uh i think it's a a great
treaty
and uh as for your point about uh
non-tariff barriers
yes i think it's it's important to
stress uh
what i'm talking about is uh barriers on
on the grounds of uh
you know uh your plugs won't work in our
in our country therefore they're banned
or whatever
um that that kind of that kind of
technical barriers to trade and there's
a lot in this treaty to try to reduce
all that kind of thing make sure that
doesn't uh that doesn't happen that's a
good thing that's a good thing
for businesses and and consumers and in
that sense it's a great free trade deal
but uh i must stress to people getting
ready for
january the first that um you know there
will be change
so people will need their as you know
get on the gov uk website
exporters will need their aor reforms
and uh and everything else people should
be aware of the change
that is coming but there's also an
opportunity because
for british exporters now the whole
world
will be treated the same for export
purposes and i think that would actually
galvanize our exporters to think much
more positively
and dynamically about the the
opportunities that they have so
uh i i must respectfully disagree with
both the points that uh
that you made this is a this is a a
jumbo canada style
uh free trade deal uh of exactly the
kind that i think this country needs and
it
and as i say i believe it resolves a
long-standing
and uh very very difficult uh problem
uh people said you couldn't uh be part
of the
uh of a free trade zone with the eu
without being
obliged to uh follow uh eu
laws if you remember uh people i i think
there was a
it was i think we were told we couldn't
have our cake and eat it and that kind
of
uh thing i'm not going to i'm not going
to claim that this is a caked
uh treaty uh robert but um
uh you know it's it's uh because that
but it is it is i i believe
uh what the country needs at this time
and uh the right way forward for
for the uk let's go to sam coats of sky
i'm going to say you say this is an
unprecedented deal that observes all
your red lines and promises to the
country
can people trust that life will be
better as a result of this deal and that
there won't be any disruption
even in the short term and can you
guarantee the government won't up
end up reopening elements of the new
relationship in the years to come
well sam i mean really good really good
questions i mean short term
uh yes as i said just now there are
things we have to get right
process that the processes that maybe
people have to
to to do that they need to be aware of
and i'm going to
that point really is worth uh
reinforcing
i do believe that the freedoms that this
treaty wins us
basically uh a new independence from
uh the eu are worth having but you know
uh and so free ports free trade deals
being able to
uh do as i say uh to to look after your
uh your your livestock differently uh
improving your your your your landscape
in a different way
uh doing all sorts of things differently
regulating financial services
differently
uh chemicals there's all sorts of things
where we want we may want to do things
differently and and better but i would
just say to
to people watching this i'm sorry for
disturbing cars 3 by the way
uh to say to people watching this i
would say it's one thing to get freedom
winning freedom is a fantastic thing and
and that
this is an important element of what
we've done but it's how we use it
how we make the most of it uh that's
what's going to matter in the
in the in the months and years to come i
have no doubt that we can do
uh fantastic things uh with this treaty
if we uh
with this new relationship which i think
will be stable
and prosperous for for both sides let's
go to
to tom newton done of times radiate
good afternoon prime minister and thank
you a couple of uh
quick questions if you don't mind every
deal
means both sides have to compromise do
you accept that
you have compromised throughout the last
11 months particularly perhaps the last
11 days from perhaps your earlier
slightly absolutist positions perhaps
that was a
negotiating ploy but compromise is not a
dirty word do you agree with that
secondly can you address services
because i haven't
heard you say much about that 80 of
course the uk
economy you say some british companies
would you do more trade with the eu
because of this deal
will the british service state
especially the financial services sector
will they be able to do more trade or
less trade well
there's a there's a first of all on the
compromise point that compromise isn't a
dirty word and we
and unquestionably there are things that
uh we've done
uh to help our friends and partners to
to move things forward
you know i i mentioned i think to laura
uh
where we got to on fish uh we you know
we
we started out uh wanting uh a very
short
um uh transition period uh
uh of of three years they wanted a much
longer one of 14 years we've
we've compromised on that at five and a
half
and on on you know uh sir the
vital services sector uh yes of course
uh
they will that they they feature in this
uh in this deal quite
quite rightly uh for that there's a
there's a some
good language about equivalence for uh
financial services
uh perhaps not as much as uh as we would
have liked but it is nonetheless
uh you know going to enable our dynamic
city of london
uh to get on and prosper as as never
before there's some good stuff about
um uh barristers solicitors lawyers
uh being able to uh practice uh around
the
uh the european union uh we will be able
to uh continue to have massive
and growing uh economic interpenetration
uh without the need for um uh
what i've always talked about this this
lunar pull
of uh of eu law this uh and and
as i say this is this is something that
i think can benefit
uh people on both sides of the of the
channel be a healthy
dynamic productive happy stable
relationship that's what we're aiming
for
let's go to george parker of the ft
thank you prime minister mentioned the
change that will happen at the border in
any event on january the 1st
i just wondered if there was anything in
this deal where the two sides have
agreed to
introduce some sort of flexibility at
the board to make sure we don't have
chaos
in dover and calais on january the first
and a second more general point um you
and i used to be reporters in brussels
and we've covered the
psycho drama of british eu relations for
a number of decades nigel farage said
today that the war
is over i just wondered if you saw it in
those terms
no i think the uh first of all on on uh
on on the border and measures to uh
there are
there are all sorts of things in the
treaty that uh what you will recognize
about trusted
uh traders schemes and uh special
measures on sanctuary and phytosanitary
uh recognition and and steps to uh
uh make sure that you know things flow
as smoothly as we possibly can though
again i stress that there will be things
that people
have to do look i mean the the one of
the great
the eu was a an ex wasn't is an
extraordinary
concept and it was born out of the agony
of the
of the second world war uh founded by
uh idealistic people uh in france and
germany
uh and italy uh who who never wanted uh
those countries to go to war uh with
each other again and
and other countries uh belgium holland
and others
and uh in many ways it's an it wasn't is
a very noble
enterprise so i you know i don't
recognize that the kind of language that
you
that you talk about i i think that the
uk's own relationship with it was
always difficult uh we always found some
of the
the language about ever close to union
the idea of
uh of this political uh union this very
dense idea of
of of this ideology of endless
integration we found quite hard
george and i think you you know as a
fellow brussels uh
reporter you'll remember that there was
there was quite a lot of friction
involved i think that what we've got
here is the basis of a new
long-term friendship and partnership
that basically
stabilizes that relationship and
insofar as the uk needs to be always
must be a great european power
always must be a great great european
power where they're
outside the main body of the of the eu
but we're there as a friend and as a
supporter as a
as a flying buttress if you like uh that
uh to make sure
as we have done so many times in the
last uh couple of hundred years that
we're able to lend our voice when it's
uh when it's needed
to be of value to our european friends
and partners in
a strategic way and that's what the uk
will obviously continue to do
but i think the the the very dense
program of integration wasn't right for
the
for the uk and that's why it was right
to take back control in the way that we
that we have and i think that uh
this deal this deal expresses uh what
the people of the country
uh voted for in in 2016 and i think
there was a wisdom in what they decided
and uh i think that we'll be able to go
forward on this basis let's go to
gordon rayner of the telegraph
thank you prime minister and merry
christmas for tomorrow
um could i just ask uh probably
half the people watching this right now
would have voted romaine
uh in the referendum in 2016.
do you have a particular message for
them
you know people today are tweeting that
uh this is a
bad deal that it's not what they what
they wanted they would rather have
stayed in
what's your message to them um and just
secondly could i also ask you
we've had more figures today on kobit
you mentioned covered earlier
um can you rule out uh another national
lockdown after christmas
uh well gordon thanks i think my message
to
everybody on both sides of the divide is
i
of that argument in 2016 is i really
think we it's now
a long time behind us and i think most
people
that i talked to whichever way uh they
were inclined to vote
back then just want it settled and want
us to move on
and i think this gives us the the
platform uh the foundation
for a really prosperous new relationship
and i would be very excited
uh now by by this this deal you know
this european question has been going on
for decades
uh exactly what relationship uh we
should have
uh this is a a great new free trade deal
uh with a a trading relationship and
partnership
that i think will uh bring prosperity to
to both sides of the channel
and um on
uh coronavirus and uh the the struggle
there
uh obviously we face very considerable
uh new pressures particularly from the
the the new variant and the speed with
which that's been
uh that's been spreading uh we
believe that uh we're going to have to
get through this
tough period now with as i say as i said
many times
very tough restrictions with tough
tearing
and you'll have seen what's been
announced over the last
day or so about that and and much as i
regret
that i do think it is necessary for us
to grip this virus
now to stop it running out of control uh
in in january
uh because we need to buy ourselves time
to get the vaccine into as many arms
of the elderly and vulnerable as we can
and that is the that is the real way in
which we will uh
defeat the the virus so it's it's tough
tiering
community testing and and rolling out
the vaccine and
we're going to continue with with that
approach
and i i know that uh
it's been very very tough over the last
few weeks and i must tell people it will
continue
uh to be difficult uh not least
basically because of the the speed with
which the
new variant is is spreading but the
vaccine is going into people's arms and
there really is
now i think i hope uh the certainty
that uh we will have it uh we will have
it defeated as i say
uh by uh by the spring or that's
certainly what the scientists
uh still believe and they're still uh
they're still confident of that
so thanks very much gordon let's go to
to harry cole of the sun
thank you prime minister can you give us
some more details about this new
security arrangements with the eu
are we going to be as safe uh next week
in your under your new security
partnership as we are today
given this brussels are saying that
they're going to lock us out of live eu
databases
and uh given you've locked us all up how
we recommend we celebrate leaving the eu
next week
well uh harry look i i leave your
your manner of celebration entirely to
to to you and to individual tastes i
wouldn't i wouldn't want i mean we've i
think
we've done quite enough bossing people
around and recommending this all that
over the last uh last 10 months or so
uh but on on security and uh police
cooperation i'm you know
absolutely confident this is a uh a deal
that protects our
uh police cooperation protects our
ability to
uh catch criminals and uh to share
intelligence across uh the european
uh continent in the way that uh we have
done uh for for many years so
i i don't think people should have
fears on that score or indeed on
any score let's go to heather stewart of
the guardian
hello prime minister um it it michelle
barnier said today that we decided to
leave the erasmus
exchange scheme which sent thousands of
students to eu countries every year
i wonder what you'd say to young people
who feel as though opportunities to
discover the constant on our doorstep by
living there or studying there or
working there are being taken away from
them
um and secondly just do you have a
message for kierstama who will have to
decide in the coming hours and days
how to whip labour mps whether whether
they should support your deal
uh right uh heather will look on the on
on erasmus it was a tough decision uh
the issue really was that
um as you know the the uk is a massive
net contributor to
the continent's higher education economy
because uh over the last
uh decades we've uh had so many
uh eu nationals which we've uh it's been
a wonderful thing
uh but our arrangements basically mean
that financially the uk exchequer
uh more or less loses out on the on the
deal erasmus was also extremely
uh expensive so what we're doing is uh
producing a
uh a uk uh
scheme for students to go around the
world and it'll be called the turing
uh scheme and it will so so students
will have the opportunity to
uh known after alan turing so the
students will have the opportunity not
just to go to european
uh universities but to go to uh the best
universities
uh in the world because we want our our
young people to experience uh the
immense intellectual uh stimulation of
uh of
europe but also of the of the whole
world and as for
i think you you asked about which way
should the opposition vote on this
well it's perfectly obvious uh uh
heather the opposition should vote
for this excellent deal and uh and i
would strongly encourage
everybody to do the same thank you very
much everybody happy christmas
to you all thank you